bonsoir
dans quelques secondes
quelque part en france un homme une
femme un enfant peut être va faire une
tentative de suicide
et ce toutes les quatre minutes
voyez je vous l'avais dit
l'autre chiffre que vous voyez là haut
c'est le chiffre des morts
une tentative de suicide toutes les
quatre minutes
un suicide toutes les 40 minutes
alors je suis d'accord avec vous c'est
pas un sujet est très facile c'est pas
un sujet très facile parce qu'on parle
de mort on parle de souffrance et que
tout ça ça nous fait peur et la peur
elle nous sert à construire des mythes
des a priori qui vont nous permettre de
nous protéger
l'un de ces mythes de ses a priori c'est
le suicide est inévitable celui qui veut
se donner la mort quoi qu'on fasse va se
donner la mort et ce soir
cet après midi on est là ensemble pour
mieux vivre ensemble et mieux vivre
ensemble ce n'est pas vivre à côté
mieux vivre ensemble c'est être capable
justement de regarder la souffrance de
l'autre de l'écouté de l'entente de la
recevoir éventuellement pour orienter et
heureusement qu'il ya des gens qui ont
su s'affranchir de ses a priori qui ont
su s'affranchir de cette peur parce que
grâce à eux
depuis dix ans ce sont vingt mille vies
qui ont été épargnées
vingt mille dhs et là je ne vous parle
que des morts je ne parle pas de ce
qu'on considère comme l'entourage direct
ou indirect dervin personnes si vous
comptez bien ça fait 4 cents
trajectoire de vies épargnées par ce
malheur la 400 milles en acceptant de
s'affranchir de nos peurs sauf que ça ne
suffit pas ça ne suffit pas parce
qu'aujourd'hui encore en france il y a à
peu près dix mille personnes qui se
donnent la main et 200000 tentative de
suicide
donc il faut qu'on trouve autre chose il
faut qu'on n'invente autre chose et
surtout il faut qu'on arrive à tordre
ensemble le cou à ces a priori qui nous
reste
je vous donne un exemple moi je trouve
que c'est courageux de se suicider c'est
quand même il faut vraiment avoir du
courage pour se donner la mort
ah ouais tu trouves que c'est du courage
toi c'est plutôt de l'égoïsme de la
lâcheté et vous vous êtes dans quel camp
courage vous l'achetez comment oui je
suis d'accord avec toi c'est une vraie
connerie cette histoire de caen parce
que le suicide c'est ni une histoire de
courage ni une histoire de l'acheter
c'est une histoire de désespoir et le
désespoir
on peut agir dessus ensemble déjà en
essayant de penser autrement et en
s'affranchissant de nos peurs et de nos
a priori un autre a priori terrible
c'est simple
celui qui a envie de se donner la mort
va toujours trouver le moyen de le faire
ouais tu as raison on lui enlève la
corde il va prendre les médicaments
oui va se jeter par la fenêtre
quelle horreur quelle erreur retirez les
moyens l'accès aux moyens de se donner
la mort est sans doute la façon la plus
facile de prévenir le suicide
vous ne me croyez pas assez simple on va
partir de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
aux états unis comme vous savez il ya
des états où les armes sont en vente
libre et battant ses états il ya plus de
suicides que dans les états comparables
ou les armes ne sont pas en vente libre
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que
quand on change la législation les
courbes du suicide s'inverse en inde le
gouvernement s'est aperçu que le moyen
le plus fréquent de se donner la mort
c'était l'ingestion de pesticides
eh bien ils ont distribué juste des
petits coffres des petits coffres en
bois aux paysans pour stocker les
matières toxiques mais même pas avec une
clé non juste pour les stocker m à part
les rendre
un petit peu plus difficile d'accès eh
bien rien que ça ils ont diminué le
nombre de morts
vous voyez sont des idées toutes simples
vous vous pouvez faire ça chez vous pas
d'armes à feu à la maison
ça réduit le nombre de morts par suicide
je vous parle pas des accidents les
médicaments combien de médicaments sont
vraiment utiles dans votre pharmacie
ramener les ou à votre pharmacien
alors oui
certains disent oui ça nous fait juste
gagner du temps un peu de temps on va
retirer les moyens et ça va nous faire
gagner un tout petit peu de temps oui
mais ce temps là c'est souvent le temps
suffisant pour faire sortir quelqu'un de
sa logique suicidaire et mettre en place
avec lui les premiers embryon de
solution
ce tant il est précieux donc vous qui
n'êtes pas soignants pour la plupart
vous pouvez agir en réduisant ce passage
à l'acte et en gagnant ce temps où nous
on essaiera de trouver ensemble les
solutions des gens qui sont capables de
penser autrement de s'affranchir de
leurs peurs et de créer des dispositifs
de soins suffisants pour baisser le
nombre de suicides il en existe
notamment un don je voulais vous parler
ce soir cet homme c'est jérôme auto mais
jérôme moto était psychiatre à san
francisco san francisco ce n'est pas un
hasard
parce qu'à san francisco il ya le golden
gate bridge comme vous le savez mais
c'est devenu comme beaucoup de ponts
célèbre un pont où on vient un hotspot
de suicide un endroit où on vient plus
particulièrement se donnait la mort et
jérôme moto donc mettez en place un
certain nombre de dispositifs pour
limiter le suicide à san francisco mais
il y avait un seul woods entre duquel il
n'arrivait pas à descendre
et puis un jour il a été invité au
domicile d'un de ses patients un patient
qui était décédé qui avait sauté du pont
en allant au domicile de ce patient il a
trouvé sur la table un petit mot un
petit mot griffonné à la hâte sur ce
petit mot il était écrit je vais aller
sur le pont mais si on chemin
quelqu'un me sourit je ne souhaiterais
pas
jérôme moto s'est assis il s'est dit
mais quel gâchis qu'est ce qu'on a loupé
parce que jérôme auto le connaissait ce
patient il avait ce sujet par nos il
l'avait déjà rencontré aux urgences pour
une première tentative de suicide il
avait fait tout ce qu'il fallait penser
tiens sauf que il le retrouve cette
fois-ci mort et il s'est dit qu'est ce
qu'on a loupé il faudrait sans doute que
nous aussi dans les équipes de soi on
adresse un petit salut on est là on est
toujours là ce sourire qui permet de ne
pas sauter alors qu'est ce qu'il a fait
il s'est dit on va envoyer du courrier
c'est bête ça coûte pas cher on va
envoyer du courrier tout simplement aux
gens qui sortent des urgences après une
tentative de suicide
on va leur envoyer une lettre
personnalisée il a écrit les lettres lui
même à la main
le résultat est dans le résultat c'est
qu'il est limité le nombre de morts et
de nombre de passages à l'acte en
envoyant du courrier tous les mois quand
même mais du courrier juste ça cette
idée toute simple elle est à l'origine
d'un courant qu'on appelle les tics de
l'inquiétude
j'aime beaucoup ça ou la clinique du
souci c'est à dire la nécessité de
rester en inquiétude vis-à-vis des
sujets qui sont sortis nos dispositifs
de soins d'autres ont répliqué cette
expérience avec d'autres systèmes
notamment évince à bristol mestalla un
pont voyez le pont et le suicide
à chaque fois c'est assez lié à
distribuer cette carte
oui c'est une carte toute simple ce
qu'on appelle une carte ressources
dessus il ya juste un numéro de
téléphone 24 heures sur 24
carter en australie à envoyer des cartes
postales
ça ressemblait un peu à l'expérience de
motos jusqu'à un autre homme
le professeur guillaume les ans il
habite juste à côté d'ici il et il
travaille au chru de lille c'est lui qui
devrait être ici ce soir parce que lui
il a eu l'idée dans un premier temps de
d'appeler les gens au téléphone
systématiquement mais surtout il a eu le
génie de relire tous les travaux de ces
gens ce qu'ils avaient donné une carte
ce qui avait envoyé une carte postale ce
qui avait envoyé une lettre
ceux qui avaient téléphoné et s'est
aperçu que chacun de ses moyens
fonctionner sur une sous population
je vais pas vous détailler les études
mais c'est dit on tient quelque chose et
il a inventé un dispositif
qu'aujourd'hui s'appelle vigilance joli
mot rester vigilant à l'autre dans ce
dispositif tout commence par ce geste ce
geste il est très important parce que
c'est ils signent l'engagement des
soignants à être là si jamais ça ne se
passe pas comme on avait prévu
c'est un geste très fort juste remettre
cette petite carte alain certains seront
rappelés au téléphone certains recevront
des cartes postales certains les deux là
encore je vais pas vous détailler tout
ça le résultat trop tôt pour connaître
le résultat est ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce sont trois mille
trois cents personnes qui dans le nord
pas de calais bénéficient de dispositifs
alors ça vous dit rien si je vous donne
pas le nombre de tentatives de suicide
dans le nord pas de calais chaque année
c'est entre 10 et 12 mines
pour l'instant le dispositif intègre en
gros un tiers des tentatives de suicide
ce dispositif il est tout jeune il est
né en janvier 2015
l'autre chiffre les 60 c 60 vies sauvées
c'est 60 personnes qui quand on les a
eus au téléphone était en train de se
suicider et grâce à la collaboration
avec le samu centre 15 et je salue ici
le docteur patrick goldstein qui en est
le responsable eh bien on dispose des
moyens d'action dans l'urgence soixante
vies épargnées
rien que l'année dernière au moins 70
alors vous allez me dire oui mais nous
on n'est pas soignants c'est bien beau
ces dispositifs de soins c'est joli etc
mais qu'est ce que moi je peux faire je
vous ai dit déjà essayé de libérer votre
esprit de ses peurs de ses a priori mais
pour ceux ici qui sont journalistes
blogueurs ce qu'ils vont distribuer
l'information il faut que vous sachiez
quelque chose c'est que quand on parle
de suicide dans un média il faut en
parler avec responsabilité
pourquoi parce que sinon on risque
l'effet werther l'effet werther ça vient
d'un roman culte de la fin du xviiie
siècle il s'appelait les souffrances du
jeune werther
dans ce roman on présente le suicide
comme un acte éminemment romantique et
bien ce roman a été à l'origine d'une
épidémie de suicides en europe à la fin
du xviiie siècle
imaginez les moyens de diffusion n'y
avait pas amazon a malgré tout malgré
des moyens diffusion très limité ça a
été une épidémie de suicides et bien
encore une initiative d'eloise le
programme papageno le programme papageno
ça vient de la flûte enchantée papageno
qui est un moment papageno et tellement
désespérés parce que papa guéna sa
compagne est morte et un moment il veut
se pendre ils montrent passe la corde
autour de son cou il est tellement
désespérée il peut pas vivre sans son
amour et à trois du temps qui surgissent
trois petits lutins de la forêt qui lui
disent m'enfin mais quel crétin tu fais
tu as la clochette la clochette pour
ressusciter
tu as le moyen d'apaiser les souffrances
vous pouvez être ces petits lutins qui
disent aux gens sont suffisamment
désespérée pour ne plus voir que
quelquefois les solutions
au bout de leurs mains qu'ils ont la
solution
d'autres initiatives encore certains sur
la toile le web ont développé des sites
internet comme si comme par exemple qui
est fait par des professionnels qui a
comme objectif de montrer que les ti
sont pas tous complètement ma boule qui
vont pas vous mettre sur un divan dès
que vous dit quelque chose
mais qu'on est là aussi pour apporter
quelque chose pour soulager des
souffrances une chaîne vidéo qui
s'appelle le syllabes qui est sur
youtube utiliser les médias
d'aujourd'hui permet aussi d'aller dans
le sens de la déstigmatisation pour que
les gens en souffrance viennent plus
facilement aux soins
et puis les réseaux sociaux tant décriée
et bien savez vous que sur facebook sur
twitter vous avez les moyens de signaler
quelqu'un qui est en souffrance alors
c'est très imparfait et voyez c'est un
gros schéma c'est très compliqué mais
vous avez ces moyens là juste pour dire
à la personne qui est en souffrance qui
a des idées suicidaires que quelqu'un se
préoccupe m voilà c'est à peu près les
messages que je voulais vous passer ce
soir en espérant que vous ayez un petit
peu plus diminuer vos peurs et que vous
puissiez les uns et les autres
inventer des initiatives pour la
prévention du suicide
merci